[Music]
this women's history month our series
changing the game is profiling
extraordinary women making an impact and
on now and on the future this morning
we're talking to a beauty entrepreneur
whose e-commerce site supports brands
created by black and brown founders her
name is nikeo grieco she's a co-founder
of 13 loon in style magazine listen to
this named her one of 50 women making
the world a better place in 2022. one
that's the list you want to be on the ko
13 loon represents more than 140
different beauty brands 90 of them are
founded by entrepreneurs who are black
indigenous or people of color 13 loon
recently partnered with jcpenney to
bring those products to 650 stores
nationwide the ko grieco joins us this
morning you are on a roll my friend
congratulations save yourself a round of
applause i say bravo to you because a
recent report says that black female
entrepreneurs you know this received
less than one percent of venture capital
investments less than one percent
so when you when you launched your line
what were some of the challenges you
faced what made you say i can do this
yeah you know so i launched a beauty
line 20 years ago uh called niko beauty
based on my family beauty secrets from
kenya my grandmother was a coffee farmer
my grandfather was a medicine man so was
inspired to bring those beauty secrets
here and you know i've been raising
money on and off for the last 20 years
and what i will say is that access to
capital has been one of my biggest
challenges but i have hope because uh
the venture world is starting to look a
little different and so while there's
much work to do
um it's getting better and better you
believe in the 9010 rule what does that
mean yes so at 13 loon we adopted what
we call our 9010 rule which is 90 of all
the brands we carry are created by
people of color who make products for
people of all colors and 10 are
dedicated to fostering ally ship and so
we call an ally brand a brand that you
know may not be black or brown founded
but has long been looking to serve that
consumer long before uh the racial
reckoning and then to debunk the myth
that black and brown people just make
products for black and brown people yeah
we know that
yeah yeah we do know that so you make
products for every every single person
yeah it's it's black and brown by poc
for all as well as having ally brands
because we want to be truly truly
inclusive and that means including
everyone you know when it comes to the
ratings they say black shoppers spend a
lot of money they sure did a lot of
money on beauty product products but
many people don't believe that the
beauty industry is kept up when it comes
to representation do you think that's
true yeah you know i i think that you
know in creating 13 luna it gave us an
opportunity and a responsibility you
know i know firsthand what it's like
being a beauty founder and and trying to
get representation in big retailers and
and you know being able to serve a
larger audience and so we wanted to make
13 loon a place to make your beauty
shopping more meaningful and make it
easier for people to to do the right
thing beauty is universal it's fun we
all love it but it's also a way that we
can help to build generational wealth
through the lens of beauty and in our
black and brown communities and and and
celebrate these global beauty secrets
and give these founders who are
incredible making non-toxic amazing
ingredients makeup in all shade ranges
um hair products that work on all hair
types the opportunity to be seen so here
here's here's your pitch uh niko what
what do you bring that nobody else does
when it comes to your line what is it i
think that we really truly bring the
first of its kind truly inclusive beauty
retail platform and now stores within
our 13 loon stores at jcpenney um we all
want to see ourselves reflected on the
shelf and we you know what you see you
do and and so i think that we're
inspiring the next generation of beauty
founders to know they can do it too but
also giving these brands the opportunity
to serve a wider audience to uh be
amplified and celebrated and and share
their products with them what does 13
loon mean so 13 my i haven't heard of 13
lou my my makeup artist who i think does
a good job yeah you should see me
without this i love it all speckled up i
thought it was 13 line and she said no
13 what does it mean yeah so 13's always
been one of my favorite numbers i grew
up first generation american so i never
knew it to be you know sort of bad luck
which i think is talked about a lot in
this country and then when i started to
research the number 13 realize that it's
an it's a number of the divine feminine
it's a powerful number and loon means
moon moon and 13 full moon mateo rico
nakayo grico thank you congrats you
thanks for having me